[Music]
my first reaction was I'm going to leave
my daughter behind and then my next
thought was I gotta tell the team after
he told us I felt a person I felt like
it was just bigger than basketball
there's no point of being mad on
basketball court and then you don't mean
like there's bigger issues my
relationship with the guys I'll never
forget him I think one of the things
they definitely learned this year though
is that we all can't do this by
ourselves I'm not gonna quit I'm gonna
be here to give my daughter driving
lessons walk her down the aisle all that
stuff death is not an option to me I'm
not going anywhere
[Applause]
got me your determination is amazing
where does it come from
honestly it comes from my family I grew
up in an athletic family from baseball
players to basketball players and just
the fun of playing sports and the
determination to do your best whatever
court feels whatever you're on is always
been part of our our motto Wow
that's why you're an amazing human all
right my team I was fortunate enough to
have a great group of kids my first year
there when we won the title was my only
my second year at the school Wow and I
was able to get a great group of kids to
the first year when we lost in the
second round of the previous year when
they came back their determination was
us everything and you know there was a
kind of a situation where they didn't
want to take no for an answer it just
kind of follows suit throughout the day
how do you think that the team success
help you battle cancer our motto
throughout the year has always been be
about want to know my players are not
just players our student-athletes and
they understand that there are students
first an athlete second amen yeah and so
that our motto of being want to know is
not just to win the game is to win the
day and you know seize the day seize the
moment and even when things like
situations like cancer get you down you
just do your best to battle through and
and you know they helped me along my
family helped me and every day that all
about being one and out do you think it
helps being productive still and like
just going on about your business so it
doesn't oh yes absolutely I mean yes
there's days that you know I just can't
mm-hmm but every chance I kid you know
with the love and care for my my wife
and my daughter and of course my guys
they're like coach need to be here and
I'm like okay I'm on my way I'm on my
way
yeah yeah they're everything to me it's
beautiful that's beautiful
we know coach O'Fallon loves his team
but they love him too and wanted to tell
him in person come on out boys
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my boys are like you okay tell coach
what do you mean see why'd you want to
be here tell him what he means to you
ever since day one we they have the best
Pat's after us but we got to learn and
got real good with each other at first
you know I wasn't the best at you know
taking criticism well but no teenager in
his but yeah we all were year but he
pushed me where I didn't think I could
be pleased like he's seen that I had a
lot of potential in me and I didn't see
it F us and he just pushed me so hard I
first I you know I didn't really like I
was like with this guy and new codes he
was trying to tell me do all this stuff
but it worked out all in English easy
because he believes in you and he sees
something that you might not see it yeah
yeah so is this what do you admire about
coach O'Fallon you know he's always been
like a great person even when he first
came into the gym like I already notice
that he had a passion for basketball you
know and most of the guys here have a
passion for the game too and you know
he's just always been like a second
father to me I always see him as that
and then his diagnosis and stuff you
know like it was kind of sad there was
days where he could even no he he
couldn't like even stand and he still
managed to come in which is like really
amazing of him and like he show me that
anything that you can with dedication in
our work you can like overcome anything
I mean amazing impression I'm teenagers
is already hard enough and you've made
an an extreme one well like I said
earlier with the youth group here just
these individuals right here they're so
special to me and we our motto
besides being want to know is that we
always talked about being family that's
you know they are there till the day
they go off and venture off under the
other parts of the worlds like that
they're always gonna be my family they
always know as long as I'm around they
can always reach out to me and vice
versa and that [ __ ] is so funny I was
happen to think about you guys this
weekend and I was just like I got a text
my guys just to see how they're doing
but they I mean it's it's been an honor
and a pleasure to be a part of these
young men's lives can't wait to meet
coach O'Fallon come on out Kobe
[Applause]
can you survive between okay I wish we
had a slow light motion he went he heard
me go like ho and he went what it's just
extremely inspiration when we talk about
you know sometimes we get caught up in
the world of sports and thinking about
the significance of each game but not
understanding that the game is you know
pales in comparison to life and the
lessons that we teach as coaches and
inspirational message that he's created
for his players of the determination
fight the belief is something that's
that's way more valuable than anything
that you can learn from hitting the
game-winning shot or winning the NBA
championship Irwin at a high school
championship wherever the case may be
so it's just a true inspiration on a
team growing up playing ball and you
never know we're lucky I mean I did the
same thing like in my feel like you
never know like it doesn matter where
you come from no matter how much money
you have like that does not limit your
dreams and you can accomplish anything
and it doesn't matter what's going on I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this